example i'm i'm an hispanic man could
could i decide i was an asian man would
i have the ability to be an asian man
and challenge harvard's discrimination
because i made that decision
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and um
how you would assess standing if i if i
came in and said i have decided i
identify as an asian
[Music]
man i am
[Music]
[Applause]
we're having a little fun with you this
morning
that little meme there is credit of my
good director connor who is 30 today
that's right happy birthday connor
connor you're getting chipotle for lunch
with the guacamole extra guacamole if
you want
we had donuts for breakfast we're taking
them out to dinner because employees of
the reuben report all become fat over
time that clearly is what's going on
here guys i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben port direct message for march
24th 2022 we are live streaming on
rumble youtube for as long as they'll
have us and blaze tv please subscribe
over at rumble.com
reuben report would you do that for me
uh we got a q a for you today but we're
going to jump into some stuff in this
supreme court uh nominee hearing catanji
brown jackson is the nominee joe biden's
nominee for the supreme court and i've
noticed to call me crazy i've noticed a
slight difference in the reaction
from the media and all of the mainstream
outlets to katanji uh it seems very
different than say brett kavanaugh it
seems a little bit different we're going
to dive into it just a bit i think
something's going on there before we get
to that first the real copies have shown
up i've got the real copies this is the
real book it's here people words
chapters paragraphs who are very excited
the tour you know it and the tickets are
selling really fast a lot of the vip
tickets are already sold out uh
daverubin.com
events if you want to join us on the
tour april 18th orlando we're going to
be announcing the guest soon i think
it's someone massive massive massive i'm
not jumping the gun on that i think we
should be able to announce it hopefully
tomorrow west palm beach will announce
the guest soon that's april 19th clear
clearwater florida we've got benny
johnson april 21st in raleigh north
carolina we've got andrew clavin from
the daily wire april 22nd the willy
wonka of politics michael malus will
join me on stage april 23rd in chicago
oh we just announced this one last night
uh janmi park my good friend and and
truly like a he put the put the camera
on me for this because she's really just
an incredible person if you have not
seen my interview with janmi park a
defector from north korea her life story
is absolutely amazing
she's going to join me on stage in
chicago chicago i think is almost sold
out already as well all right we can go
back to uh to the dates there dallas
glenn beck from the blaze will be
joining me washington dc in the swamp
we've got megan mccain west niacc new
york the suburbs of new york city we've
got miss megan kelly brea california
dennis prager of prager university uh
may 12th oxnard we've got the man who
should have been governor of california
instead they've got that evil freak uh
that's larry elder on may 12th oxnard
san jose will announce the guest uh very
shortly may 16th uh that's may 15 san
jose may 16 phoenix arizona we have the
next senator i promise you he's going to
be the next senator from arizona blake
masters and may 18th denver colorado i
think i can announce the guest tomorrow
on that one we are just waiting for an
official email confirmation all right
real quick guys before we get oh and
again it's davereuben.com
events all the links are there so you
can click to the city you want to go you
can purchase your tickets you get a book
you get a book with
a ticket and if you
are a vip i'll even sign it for you i'll
take a selfie i'll sign the book that's
the way we're going to do it around here
and all right real quick before we get
to the show i want to talk to you about
american home shield you know no one
likes to think
about household breakdowns but they
happen and way more often than you'd
like that's why it pays to have a plan
from american home shield to help cover
the costs to repair and replace things
like your heating system ac or your
fridge they also know that no two homes
are the same that's why they have new
options to help you find just the right
coverage american home shield members
get more their plans help protect parts
of up to 23 essential home systems and
appliances no matter how old they are
ahs also offers electronics coverage
available for an unlimited number of
eligible items like smart watches flat
screen tvs and more other options
include roof leak repair i'm working
with them on that right now and pool and
spa coverage if american home shield
can't repair a covered item they will
replace it keep your home up and running
with and on budget and on track with
american home shield right now reuben
report listeners can take 50 bucks off
their most comprehensive plans go to
ahs.com
ruben right now and save 50 bucks that's
ahs.com reuben for 50 bucks off any plan
american home shield be sure with the
shield service fees limitations and
exclusion supply c plan for details and
now back to me okay so the big thing
happening right now
is that there are hearings to confirm
joe biden's supreme court nominee
katanji brown jackson now as a general
rule and i discussed this in my
interview with judge napolitano this
week that you may have seen as a general
rule uh the the nominee that the
president selects should basically get
through
the senate that's sort of how it should
work and how it mostly has worked when
that started breaking down actually was
in the 80s when a guy you may have heard
of this guy a guy by the name of joe
biden
started blocking robert bork he was a
conservative joe biden was a liberal and
bork did not make it to the supreme
court obviously he's not on the supreme
court
i think he passed away did robert burke
pass away i think maybe in the last
couple years um
in any event as a general rule they're
supposed to pretty much get by you want
to make sure that they don't have truly
like psychotically radical judicial
decisions and that they understand the
law and they understand separation of
powers and you can ask some questions
and but it's a little bit of a dog and
pony show
um and then you just let them pass by
but over the last couple years with amy
coney barrett and of course with brett
kavanaugh these things have become
highly politicized psychotic adventures
of lunacy
so the republicans are kind of giving it
back to the democrats right now there's
there's nobody that doesn't have fault
on this thing
but first we want to show you the
outrage the outrage that's happening
outside the supreme court this is
extraordinary outrage that you're not
seeing on other networks
these are live images folks at
the doors of the supreme court where you
can see protesters have gathered they
are demanding
that their voices be heard as they
anticipate
who will who the person who will be a
new supreme court justice
ah
you're a reuben report viewer so you're
bright you know what i did there yeah
that has nothing to do with katanji
brown jackson and her hearing that was
when they were trying to confirm brett
kavanaugh
a little bit of an insurrection you
might say you know bashing down the
doors threatening people obviously uh
these people could have gone violent at
any moment uh but that's what they were
doing the tolerant side then of course
that's not happening right now there are
just uh senators asking katanji brown
jackson legitimate questions here's
marsha blackburn senator marcia
blackburn asking
brown jackson what a woman is
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me a
definition
senator in my work as a judge what i do
is i
address disputes if there's a dispute
about a definition people make arguments
and i look at the law and i decide so
i'm not
the fact that you
can't give me a straight answer about
something as fundamental as what a woman
is underscores the dangers of the kind
of progressive education
that we are hearing about
do you see what's going on here we have
a woman who will be on the supreme court
like she's going to get through
who doesn't know what a woman is or
refuses to say what a woman is that
really is what's going on here
um she says she's not a biologist but
i'm pretty much sure that you might know
that two plus two is four you don't have
to be a mathematician
to know that you know what i mean you
don't have to be a zoologist to know the
difference between a dog and a giraffe
etc etc we had a little more fun conor
was in a good mood this morning on his
30th birthday here's a little something
for you
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context
i have nipples greg could you milk me
we are all jack burns
from meet the parents
i have nipples greg can you milk me
that is how stupid politics has become
but that in essence jack is now the good
guy
jack burns
is the good guy
that's where we're at well you know what
i didn't want to uh i don't want to just
make light of this you know what i mean
we wanted to do our research and we got
teamwork and i got a whole bunch of
staff about 80 people they keep them
downstairs i throw them fish heads once
a week and i got them they're always
banging on typewriters and all this kind
of stuff and i said to them guys guys
what is a woman can someone get me a
definition of a woman they went right to
merriam-webster dictionary and we pulled
up this
woman a human swimmer who ranks 554
in the men's division and first in the
women's division with a picture of leah
thomas
you see what we're doing with you today
it's thursday it's not friday
it's thursday but we're just doing it
we're just doing it with you okay now
joking aside what is a woman if you're
sitting there and you just don't know
you just have no idea you're looking
down you see some things and you're like
what are these things and how did they
get here and what am i
oxford dictionary on what a woman is
of or denoting the sex that can bear
offspring or produce eggs distinguished
biologically by the production of
gametes ova which can be fertilized by
male gametes
so there is a difference between chicks
and dudes
it's 2022 and somehow
that is a controversial statement
anyway uh due to what we've done here
this morning um i'm pretty sure we're
going to be banned from everything it's
been nice knowing you guys you can find
us at ruben report.locals.com and yeah
if you don't have a penis you're
probably a woman how about that
that seems
you know what i mean if you've got boobs
well now these guys these fat guys you
know these soy boys they've got these
huge breasts that doesn't make you a
woman you're just fat
you're just fat and get up get off the
computer for just a second get out there
walk it's good for the skin too
so you might you could have boobs and be
a man but most likely if you don't have
a penis
all right
reubenreport.locals.com community q a
here we go uh kathy says a few youtube
creators that i watched got canceled
this week what case can you make for
people to ditch youtube and join rumble
look rumble is a
non-partisan platform it's as simple as
that i have had a million discussions
with chris who is the ceo of rumble dan
bongino and i are helping guide policy
on rumble and our basic belief is that
as long as you don't break the laws of
the united states as long as you don't
threaten to murder somebody
as long as you're not doing outright
libel or slander which are against the
laws of the united states then you can
be on there you can't you can't put up
terrorist threats on there and things of
that nature but we're not putting our
our hand on the scale related to what
your political beliefs are there are
plenty of lefties on there there are
plenty of righties on there and anyone
you can be on there it really is as
simple as that that's the best sales job
and i will tell you this there are huge
huge plans i mean it's it's very obvious
to me my future is not youtube right
like it's not youtube the the youtube
people susan wajesky over at youtube the
ceo of youtube she does not like me
obviously i could say anything that that
little picture that we showed you before
with leah thomas and what is a woman
it's like they could just delete me
because of that you know there's certain
amount of people they they don't delete
everyone at once you know sometimes they
take out slightly smaller people it
clears out some of the brush and then
the pressure goes away and then
sometimes they take out higher people
right now on twitter if you haven't seen
this charlie kirk my buddy charlie kirk
from turning point usa he's been locked
out of twitter for a couple days because
he made a joke it was it wasn't even a
joke i mean he basically just said you
know there's a difference between men
and women i mean it was as simple as
that in essence he's been locked out of
twitter for a couple days the babylon b
has been locked out of twitter for a
couple days for actually making a joke
about what's going on here with rachel
levine and leah thomas and the rest of
it i think in america you're still
allowed to
make jokes now that's not the government
necessarily coming for them although
it's hard to tell how much the
government and big tech are colluding
together
but we need new things we need new
things and we need better things it's
why i built locals it's why we merged
with rumble and the best sales job is
we're not coming to get you we're not
coming to get you and i know we have the
right people around us to stand up to
this and i'm not just talking about
chris and asaf who runs locals and and
me and bongino i'm talking about the
lawyers the entire staff that we've met
like these people when i've been in
meetings it's like the meetings they're
they're not just about oh we're gonna
put this feature in and by the way we're
working on a lot of new features it's
also like we are going to fight the
thing and we are going to do what we all
know is right so
rumble.com ruben report for when they
boot me but even before then that that's
really where our future is obviously
nick says dave after the david's sons
are born are you going to still do your
august off the grid vacations and if so
are you going to do them during a
different month since school starts in
august here in the free state of florida
so of course the big announcement the
big life announcement was uh last week
that uh david and i are having two kids
we're having two boys uh we have two
different surrogates we're obviously
super excited we've been working on this
for a long time and uh you know there i
saw some people there was some level of
concern on the internet about having
female role model and a mother and all
of that and you know men and women while
they are biologically different some men
are more caregivers uh some women are
more hunter-gatherer are more hunters
you know what i mean like we're gonna do
the best we can to be two great parents
and provide a home that is safe and
loving and all of those things but that
being said david's mom is gonna be
spending some time down here especially
right at the beginning as well as his
sister who's been a nanny before my
sister
is here in miami and has a couple kids
and is going to help out and my mom will
be around and we're going to do all
sorts of things but to your question on
uh august off the grid i mean obviously
everything's about to change right like
i had a good 45-year run i did what i
wanted when i wanted i've been able to
build something really great here and
build a couple companies and
do what i want to do for a living and go
out when i want to go out and all of
that stuff uh that's really going to
change so the the first baby is going to
be born in august so that will certainly
change my august off the grid ability
will i be able to literally not have my
phone for a month probably not because
there's going to be some phone calls and
some travel and things like that i'm
going to still do the off the grid in
terms of no news for the month and that
sort of thing but it will slightly
change some of the ability to to not
have like an actual device in my pocket
and then as far as going forward i think
we're going to kind of just have to see
because yeah school does start early
here in florida usually around august
15th if i'm not mistaken you know
obviously we've got a couple years
before the kids are in school and also i
think school and schooling is changing
so rapidly and even though the public
schools in florida have been far less of
infected by the woke stuff
than many other schools
i don't know that we're going to send
our kids to public school i think
schooling will just look different
anyway like whether it's charter school
or private school or pods or doing
something out of our own home or
something like that we're gonna have to
think about all of these things and uh i
would say in about four years from now
if i'm doing this show and you hear
somebody screaming in the background
we're most likely homeschooling we'll
find out uh stephanie says why would
anyone bring and leave their computer to
a store to fix it mine doesn't hold
government secrets and i'd never just
leave it someplace let alone forget it
so of course you're talking about the
hunter biden laptop which was making me
think you know it's kind of funny you
know the geek squad or the dork brigade
or what do they have at uh best buy the
geek squad the dork brigade that's
something else the nerd police i don't
know whatever they are um
you know people drop their computers off
there and then wasn't there a story once
that there was some government
connection can you guys check this i
think there was that one time a story
where the government was actually
working with the geek squad or the nerd
police or the dork brigade to actually
look at people's computers so your
question is legit it's like it doesn't
mean you have something illegal on your
computer but oh so there was a story
about that okay great so the government
had something the fbi was doing
something with the geek squad so you
know you get this you know like the
average person walks in oh i can't get
my computer to work the
windows won't minimize help me geek
squad and next thing you know the fbi is
reading all your emails it's crazy it's
not about you having really horrific
[ __ ] on there or evil whatever
we just yeah we're all like working in
systems that we don't understand that
really is what it's all about
so i would not just hand my computer to
anyone like you just shouldn't do that
in that you have private emails you know
what i mean like i have private
correspondences with people not because
i'm breaking the law but we all have a
certain level of privacy that we want in
life but there is something particularly
bizarre about this that hunter biden not
only had these emails but you know it
sounds like he had some pretty horrific
images on there and a bunch of other
stuff and that he just handed the laptop
to this computer repair shop and then
basically just left it there
like what
i guess you know what maybe it's this
maybe when you're smoking crack you're
not making the best decisions
you think
i think maybe that's it i've never
smoked crack but i would imagine you're
not you know whatever
oh that's weed but like how would you
smoke crack really oh it's like a
oh it's like how you smoke parmesan
cheese yeah but there's like something
and then like i'm gonna make some good
decisions now
brad says do you think the clear
insanity of judge jackson's record and
her inability to answer basic questions
will matter in her confirmation no i
don't because everything is partisan um
they have the votes they have the votes
and as i said at the top you know
generally speaking unless someone has
truly like an
abysmal record like
something that you can point to that
legally is so profoundly wrong that in
essence
it is the president's duty to nominee to
nominate the person and then it's the
senate's job to confirm that making sure
that it's nothing crazy not that they
have to agree with everything that the
senators want so the the hearings are a
certain level of just a show it's just a
show but it is important so that when
they make once she is confirmed and
she's going to be confirmed once she is
confirmed that as we get decisions over
the next couple years potentially the
next few decades we're able to point to
the beginning and go boy you know she
didn't know what a woman was or not that
she didn't know what a woman was but she
was afraid to say what a woman was so
that if there is a supreme court case
you know if it ever makes it up to the
supreme court say um
say how about this one
say a bunch of female swimmers sue the
ncaa because all of the female swimmer
medals are now going to all men
biological men and then they sue the
ncaa if that court case ever got up to
the supreme court well now we could
point back to katanji brown jackson
saying i don't know i'm not a biologist
so how the hell am i supposed to know
what a woman is so you want just sort of
a track record it doesn't necessarily
stop anything but then you can at least
understand
not only their judicial philosophy but
their their personal philosophy there
was also a question that was asked of
her as to whether when she thinks
life begins
and she completely punted that and
didn't answer and it's like you know she
can have whatever her opinion is on
abortion and she can have whatever her
opinion is on roe v wade which as i
always say is not about legal abortion
it's about kicking it making it a
federal law not a state law
but if you're afraid to answer those
very difficult questions
that's a red flag to me again it's not
going to stop her
but that would be a red flag in my mind
uh jeff says can jordan peterson be your
kid's godfather um i don't want to give
away too much on that department but
that would be a pretty freaking
good
godfather right i mean how much better
would it get than that and you know as
you guys know
um you know being on tour with jordan
was really the the final move for me in
the decision to have kids because david
had wanted kids for many years
and he's a little bit younger than me he
grew up knowing he was going to be
married knowing he was going to have a
family and all that i was born in 76
like when i was a kid
in the 90s like there was no oh you're
going to get gay married or you're going
to have a future or a family or any of
those things i didn't really think about
them in a weird way but there was no
like there was no vision of that you
know it just it didn't exist
and because of that i really never
thought about having kids i never
thought about getting married that then
then we got married and then
you know life continues life continues
and life is supposed to be something
that you're always building upon to
hopefully get a little bit better
at things you know as jordan talks about
you know if you get imagine if you got
one percent better every day you know
where you'd be in a week and a half when
it really starts compounding you know
and it starts really moving forward like
you can turn things around pretty
quickly and you know sometimes you
really do it and then sometimes you
don't but david really wanted kids
and when we were in europe on the tour
uh jordan often was talking about the
importance of being a father not that
and a mother not that everyone has to do
it to live a fully actualized life but
most people do that it's such a profound
experience
in terms of raising someone giving them
values
protecting someone else all of those
things that it's one of the things that
helps you complete the journey of being
a human being and then
perhaps hopefully after that being a
grandparent et cetera et cetera so i'm
hearing from david that he wants kids
and i'm hearing from jordan the
importance of it and those two things
really came together and and i actually
am excited i'm you know i'm i would say
i'm a little nervous or i'm a little
just every day i wake up now and i'm
like man the clock is ticking you know
like ah what are we gonna do uh but
it's it's life like it's life and there
are sometimes things that are bigger
than you so there you go
uh so i don't know we'll see about the
godfather thing um meg says will you do
an update on glenn younkin since he's
been in office he's been working hard in
virginia well look the main thing i'll
gladly do something on him next week why
don't we do a little that would be a
good idea actually do a little recap of
when we get a win right we get a
governor who's going to fight critical
race theory okay he's been
he's been running the state now in
virginia for for a couple months it's
like well what's going on over there so
we'll do a little recap on that next
week from what i basically understand
he's been fighting the critical race
theory stuff and that's that's the main
thing that he promised and that is the
main thing he's doing so seems pretty
good to me seems pretty good to me
uh sarah says congratulations on the
bundles of joy on the way do you and
david plan on keeping them out of the
public eye why or why not that's a great
question
the quick answer is yes
um you know i happen to be a public
person
there's a lot of goodness that comes
with that there's some negativity that
comes with that
um you know there's been a particularly
nice warm part of it that's happening
here in florida i went out to dinner
with douglas mario last night and
another friend and
you know tons of people are coming up to
me throughout the dinner and it's always
nice and everyone's respectful and take
a couple pictures and all those things
they just say nice things and welcome
you to florida and it's all good so
that's the nice part of it but then
there is some other part
actually i can't say that i've ever been
really bothered when anyone's come up to
me because people are always nice but
there is some other part where you feel
like you have to share things that maybe
you wouldn't necessarily be sharing and
then hear a reaction from people that
you don't particularly care about that
don't have anything to do with you so
when they're even though 99 of what we
got in the last week was love and we got
it from from tons of conservatives tons
of conservatives i didn't really get any
love from liberals
actually i got tons of love from
conservatives um and you guys whatever
you are it doesn't even matter what the
label is right got tons of love on that
front um but there was some
like more fringe people that are not
happy and that are saying mean things
about me and it's like all right we live
in a free country i'm allowed to live my
life you're allowed to say mean things
about me that's a weird part of being
public that when you do something that's
really private with your family we sort
of had to say something right
at some point i was going to have to say
something because eventually
i was going to have kids in this house
and i'd be talking about it perhaps but
i don't intend on plopping a kid right
here and you know doing uh doing a show
with the kid on the on the table uh so
clyde will still be getting more
pictures online than the kids
but part of it also was that you know
uh when you're having kids
male female gay or straight uh people
like to post pictures they like to post
pictures of the
uh
of the images they like to post pictures
of
like the little shoes and the socks and
all of the stuff right and um and david
wanted to do that as all his friends
have been doing something similar to
that so i felt that if he's going to do
that then enough people are going to
know i'm going to have to do something
here and again it was 99 love so uh it's
all good
janice says what is something you love
about your neighborhood
that surprised you
that surprised me i thought it was going
to be good and it's been good i would
say a few more lizards than we
anticipated a lot of i saved the lizard
this morning meant to take a picture of
it there was a lizard in the kitchen
this morning i caught the lizard in a
bowl and a plate
brought the lizard outside saved the
lizard uh that's what i'm doing in the
morning so you're saving lizards um has
there anything been about my
neighborhood that surprised me um well
look you know i think i mentioned this
last week but you know miami's got some
traffic right now and it's got traffic
and the best sense of traffic because
there's a lot of people moving here and
there's an incredible amount of
construction because when you're doing
something right people want to be part
of it so there's a little of that
but has anything else surprised me
no everybody's great i got a great flea
market near where we are on sundays and
uh people are pleasant and
lovely
the heat and the humidity has been i
know it's the winter now we're at the
beginning of spring uh but there was the
concern is it can is the humidity going
to lower the hair but i think the height
is is pretty solid so i have no
complaints no surprises in any negative
sense it's it's just been good really uh
cat says did the possibility of raising
kids in the near future have any
influence on your decision to leave
california and move to florida great
question yes absolutely 100
because
even though once the recall failed and
then three days later i got audited by
the state because they used the levers
of power to punish their political
opponents that was the final straw but
for a year and a half i was pissed and
not happy there and you know i was happy
in my day-to-day life
but i rarely went out everyone was
depressed p i would have illegal parties
where people would come and everyone
would be complaining we'd have great
time but everyone was also like when are
you leaving it's horrible here like
eventually it becomes it becomes enough
enough but then on the kid thing
it was very obvious i was not going to
raise my kids in california and well
certainly a hundred percent at a public
school level but the private schools the
religious private schools the jewish
schools the the catholic schools they've
all been infected actually you'll find
this super interesting uh many of the
the jewish schools have been so infected
by woke-ism
that uh campbell hall which is one of
the biggest catholic michael correct me
if i'm wrong on this it's one of the
biggest catholic private schools in los
angeles it's now something like 40
jewish so you've got the same jews are
now sending their kids to catholic
private school
because that's one of the last bastions
of non-wokeness so the whole thing was
so screwed up and i have plenty of
friends obviously that have kids from
toddlers
to into their 20s and everybody talks
about it at every level whether you're
going to a college you know whether
you're going to usc
uh and i had uh i have a friend who
has a young son at usc and just hearing
the horror stories out of that or
whether it's the gender identity stuff
in third graders at the public school or
somewhere i was just like we can't do
this we can't have any part of this and
uh you know we have a little bit of a
window the other thing related to kids
that helped the move
was that when you have kids it gets much
harder to move right i have friends that
are back in l.a right now that mainly
are stuck there because of kids because
your kids have friends and a baseball
and all of those things and then it
becomes much harder to to pick up and go
so we had a window that i knew was
closing on our ability where it was like
all right it's me david and clyde
and the three of us can get the hell out
of dodge right now but the longer we
wait knowing that we're working on kids
the more that's going to tie us here so
yeah it was a part of getting out of
there um oh this is a great question
seven has locals or rumble been
pressured to block access from russia or
to censor discussions about ukraine the
answer is yes and we have not uh
acquiesced to anything i will leave it
at that um i will leave it at that
nate says if greg gutfeld
aka the king of late night he is the
king of late night brings his show to
florida for a week like he's done in
nashville in dallas already can we count
on your epic o.g guest return to the
show yes absolutely he was in nashville
he wanted me to come and do a couple
nights there and then he invited me to
the dallas thing too to do some shows
and it was just obviously between the
move and trying to get the book launch
in order and everything else it was just
really tough to do but i i love greg you
know i always tell you one of the one of
the cool things of knowing some of these
people these public people privately is
when you know somebody that's that's
truly the same
when they're just exactly the same how
they are on camera and off camera and i
would say if i just
these are the three that just popped
into mine i would say greg
same on camera as off camera talks
exactly the same way
curses the exact same way like you're
getting the same freaking guy on camera
off camera candace owens exactly the
same
exactly the same as fearless and direct
and and fun and joyous and happy and all
of that stuff and then of course jordan
peterson exactly the same on camera and
off camera that's that's not an
exhaustive list
uh i think i'm pretty much the same on
camera as off camera um but that i
always think that's a mark of sort of
like a full a full human being so yeah
i'd love to do more with greg and i
really wanted him to come open for me on
one of the our book tour stops uh but
you know he's doing a five day a week
live show at night on fox so that does
make a little bit difficult
vika says are you open to having guests
on the show that have several diverging
opinions from yours yes and i'm
completely open to your suggestions on
this look it's gotten more difficult
over time i used to have a lot more
lefties on and then i was talking about
why i wasn't happy with the left and
then suddenly i started getting called a
racist and a bigot and then most lefties
just said we're not going to talk to you
anymore so interestingly i've had more
guests on the right
that i disagree with about this or that
than people on the left anymore right so
if i disagree
with say ben shapiro on abortion or
dennis prager on the death penalty
or
glenn beck on abortion i mean i've
debated these things with a bunch of
these guys and not even debated just
honestly discussed it with them
there is a difference of opinion there
but i think what happens is people are
like oh but you guys roughly like each
other you're all kind of probably voting
in the same way so even if you have
differences of opinion it doesn't count
to me that shows the strength of what i
would say is a wide tent conservative
movement or or a wide tent x-lib
conservative
thing you know some sort of amalgamated
wedged wielded and welded together thing
um that's the strength of it that these
people can have these conversations um
even the conversation that i had on
glenn's show this past week about about
raising kids as a gay couple it's like
that's an important conversation to have
not something that is really being had
you know you only hear one thing about
gays which is it's the lgbtqi movement
and we better love them and they've got
87 flags and you better bow to them i'd
rather it's like that's not really a
conversation glenn and i had an
extremely
personal powerful conversation and i
actually just think we just scratched
the surface
of of what parenting is like
um and what a same-sex couple having
kids is like and the importance of
family and all of those things but
nobody looks at that and is really like
oh look at them they're so different and
yet they're having these conversations
it's more like ah they kind of agree and
it's like that's not really true
but we respect each other as human
beings um but i think in essence you're
asking me about about more lefties and
yeah if you can find some that are truly
willing to engage properly that haven't
that haven't attacked me mercilessly
unfairly or unjustly sure i'll continue
that conversation
um
but i would say let me just say one
other thing on that which is that i'm
i'm actually much more interested in
building new things and building
parallel structures and fighting for the
state that i live in and things like
that so i'm not really interested in in
whittling down all the arguments that i
had for years anymore and having someone
really try to explain to me why
affirmative action is good right i'm
sort of past that point that's i'm not
saying people can't have those
conversations but i'm actually not that
interested in that what i want to fight
for is how do i build
a better state that i live in and fight
to keep this state free how do we build
better products like i did with locals
and rumble how do we how do we
further the ideas that i talk about here
so that more young people won't be
infected by wokism actually that's
very much what this new book is all
about uh brad says in response to your
long format shows this week and the
events taking place now
the most important question to answer
about these events and actions to what
end right so what we tried to do this
week with the show and full credit to
phoenix on this is we tried to build a
narrative this week there where the
first couple days we were showing you
all of the things that the democrats and
the media and the powers that be
are are doing and they're doing wrong
and they're trying to usher in
this this new world order we tried to
expose some of the hunter biden stuff
and how twitter hides it and the
mainstream media hides it we tried to
show you how the policies
of joe biden the policies of the
democrats are causing gas prices to go
up and they're causing the supply chain
stuff and the policies of screwing
over the good people of afghanistan who
are helping us and leaving them like
that create a situation where our allies
don't trust us so we did that for a
couple of days and then what we wanted
to counter that with yesterday was but
there are places that are doing it right
and florida is the tip of the spear of
doing it right and that's why i want to
focus on building things i want to i
want that model the model of this state
the model of the governor that we've got
here rhonda said that model is the thing
that should be replicated and sent
throughout the nation so that's really
what we tried to do this week is show
you here's the here's the bad stuff
that's happening
here's seemingly why they're doing it
and here's the good stuff that's
happening so i think that's why we'll i
appreciate the earlier question on glenn
younkin we'll do some kind of review on
that and see where things are going in
virginia let's let's start let's start
racking them up what states are
functioning and what states aren't and
and for the functioning ones what are
their weak points for the for the ones
that are that are not necessarily
working do they have any strong points
are any of the policies right or is it
just always everything's bad california
is kind of in the always everything bad
category
really is really is across the board now
gavin newsom well i just mentioned
california and gavin newsom got to put a
little money in the fund to get someone
to escape cali um
gavin newsom is talking about giving
people a
tax credit no not a tax credit a rebate
a gas rebate
now which means that you'll the
government will give you money because
of the prices of gas that are high which
have everything to do with joe biden's
policies and his policies which is why
gas is more expensive way more expensive
in california than in florida right now
the government finds problems creates
problems and demands that they're the
answers
that's how it works
uh kevin says how many years did it take
you to become an overnight success did
you always want to be a talk show host
you know it's funny um
who was it i was with um
susie esman
once comedian susie essman who you may
know as susie green from
curb your enthusiasm
and i was with her once on the subway in
new york city so it was sort of like we
were in an episode of curb or seinfeld
or something and i said hi to her and we
had a couple mutual friends
and um she said something i thought was
really interesting she's like and she
sort of sounds like susie on the show
she's like you know everyone thinks i'm
an overnight success but it's like where
the [ __ ] were you for the first 20 years
these [ __ ] people
and so people think that that you know
this overnight success idea it's like
most first off if you if you're a real
overnight success meaning you're sort of
nobody doing nothing then you have some
like great moment
or viral moment or whatever most likely
you're not going to be a long-term
success because i think one thing that
in retrospect i'm very appreciative now
is i spent years and years on the street
corners of new york city six nights a
week sometimes three hours a night sleep
nor rain nor snow did not stop me
handing out comedy club tickets so that
i could
get on stage work basically for free
often then in the later years then you
start getting paid uh to just hone my
craft be comfortable speaking to a crowd
doing crowd work messing around i i knew
comics that were incredible incredible
saying the truth and most of them
disappeared because they couldn't take
it because it's a shitty business and
they couldn't take the the pain and all
of that stuff i know guys that were
pretty crappy comics that are big stars
right now and i know and i know some in
between out of my crew of comics that
you know everyone you've always got your
kind of crew of people um the one that
became a real mainstream success who was
who was just an awesome incredible
talent she's just a great gal uh melissa
rauch who you guys probably know as
bernadette from the big bang theory uh
is a great friend of mine and i i just
knew the first time i saw her that she
was just going to be a star i said to
her the first night i remember we were
in the times square subway station after
the first night we did stand up together
and i said you're going to be the first
one on snl that's back when comics
wanted to get on snl because it was a
good show a long time ago she never got
on snl but obviously she she killed it
with big bang
um
so
i yeah i was not an overnight success it
was a long slog and i think one of the
things that people appreciate i suppose
about what i do is that you know i've
been honest about the journey i've been
honest about the journey when you when
you go back if you if you ever go back
and you watch the young turks clips of
me supporting bernie sanders it's like
that was legit and then you can watch me
sort of waking up you can watch those
moments you can watch the larry elder
moment and uh and then suddenly you go
man i'm 45 and
i guess this is successful and it's
pretty good and all of those things but
you're sort of never fully there i guess
i guess in a way you know it's like you
never fully like oh did i really
accomplish the thing that i wanted to
accomplish or or what's next or what's
on the horizon and then i suppose one
day
when you're older eventually you take
your your foot off the pedal a little
bit i'm not quite there yet but let's
revisit this once i have a couple kids
and i come into the show in the morning
and there's like you know
throw up on me and my hair's out of
whack and i have huge bags under my eyes
people it's all over uh cobalt says are
you going to do a show in miami or
broward county we'd love to see you live
so yeah we're starting with three
florida shows it's uh orlando on april
18th west palm beach on uh april 19th
and clearwater which is the tampa
area uh that is on the 20th i believe
right those are guys those are back to
back 18th 19th yeah i did it okay there
you go there's a couple of the other
dates um we wanted to do something local
in miami the market is a little wacky
right now and we couldn't find the right
theater that they were going to be
that it was going to fully work within
the schedule and everything else but 100
yes
my original intention was i wanted to
open this thing in miami we were going
to try to do it maybe at the jackie
gleason theater which is where jordan
did
uh his show here which is an awesome
it's a huge theater it's awesome
um it just didn't work out scheduling
wise there was also because of because
of my policy on no masks and no mandates
there was a lot of scheduling things
that we constantly had to be moving
around because there were policies that
were changing policies that still could
change
i know a few of you have mentioned that
i suppose i think on the dc improv show
website
um that it still has up there that you
have to have a mask or something or you
have to have a passport saying it's 100
not true they just haven't taken it off
the site i promise you i am not
performing anywhere where they're going
to ask you for a vaccine card or
passport or make you wear a mask
or make you wrap tape around your mouth
and write gay on it or any other idiotic
moronic thing that is my promise
to you
uh oh we got a funny clothes for you
today yeah should we you know what we're
gonna do we're gonna we're gonna throw
you something we're gonna the cold open
it's gonna be the cold closed today uh
and we're gonna post it also on social
so you'll be able to snag it that little
ted cruz milan thing uh so you can share
it around uh guys one more quick
reminder uh the tour is here
daverubin.com
events i'm not gonna repeat everything
again but tickets are going fast and i
hope to meet as many of you as possible
every single ticket comes with a book
and you're going to dig it it's going to
be fun and heartfelt and honest and
there'll be some surprises and all that
good stuff
that's all i have to say about that i
will see you tomorrow happy birthday
connor
extra guacamole my friend that's right
we spare no expense all right see you
tomorrow guys for example i'm i'm an
hispanic man could could i decide i was
an asian man would i have the ability to
be an asian man
and challenge harvard's discrimination
because i made that decision
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and um i'm asking you how
you would assess standing if i if i came
in and said i have decided i identify as
an asian man
[Music]
[Applause]